I'm not sure we're gonna be able to get
these shoes I'm doing my very best holy
crap
hopefully Kane feels the same way first
half was a punch yes I hired a
professional liberty personal assistant
hi I'm Kane and I've always wanted to
have a personal assistant this week I
finally get the chance it is really hard
to get the little things done at home so
many things that I procrastinated on I'm
excited for this to change my life so I
can be a proper adult so I contact a
pocketbook agency the pocketbook agency
is a corporate and domestic staffing
agency and we serve everybody from
founders co-founder CEOs we run the
gamut from working with regular families
and celebrities across the nation
they're gonna connect me with someone
who can help me best with my needs my
name is Kevin and I'm a personal
assistant I'm afraid that I'll be a mean
boss I won't have anything for them to
do I'll have too much for them to do
personal assistants do a variety of
different things they'll pick up your
car put gas in the car for you go to the
grocery store the answer your phone for
you the list goes on and on nothing is
ever too big or too small
celebrities tend to hire people that are
24/7 I'm a little interested to see how
much he really needs a personal
assistant for because I don't know if
it's that much he goes day one took me
over to his house I met his dog Marty
got the rundown on how to take care of
Marty did have a nice lunch and we got
to chat and talk about our hopes and
dreams the more I know who am i working
for the quicker I can just get things
done five steps ahead of them I enjoy
out of knowing that their day went well
because of my day going well got a test
a bun before all the tests actually
starts pains really cool super nice
super easy to work for so about this
iMac five years ago and since working at
BuzzFeed we have a laptop so I don't
need it it's just sitting there
gathering dust I just have no idea where
to sell it how much it's worth or I have
the time or energy to sell it my goal is
to get this
best price possible I'm gonna try to do
it on Craigslist if that doesn't work
I'll take it to my comeback yourself he
said the lowest he would go it was 800
but honestly I really want to get 1,500
for it because I want to impress so
there are these really really
comfortable shoes called all birds and
I've been wanting them for a long time I
just don't know where or how to get them
hopefully Kevin can help me figure it
out I reached out to them and they don't
have stores here they only have two
stores one in San Francisco one in New
York probably not gonna be able to get
it unless it's shipped to us have a
shift next day could be really costly so
that's the end of day 1 no tests have
actually been completed yet I think a
lot of it was just Kevin getting to know
my life today is day 2 a lot of us
personal assistants sometimes we have
the craziest things to do for our
clients so I'm waiting for like Caine to
think of something like that so I have a
beautiful dog named Marty and medicine
in a few videos before having a dog is
great but it's like having a child there
are so many responsibilities marty is
due for a grooming and I've been meaning
to take him to a place that babysits
dogs when you're out of town but it
takes an hour for an evaluation this
sounds like the perfect task for a
personal assistant there's Marty oh my
god so cute we're gonna get Marty
evaluated for daycare he's a little
nervous they won't let me in the room
because they don't want him getting
destroyed
but I'm gonna say he's a little scared
backs and walks lets you foster dogs
we've kept the cage because we didn't
have time to go return it right now
we're just sitting near our toilet
little things like that that you don't
really think uh is gonna be really
helpful I'm here in West LA at wags and
walk Dean wanted me to deliver these
crates and we are back a healthy spot
picking up Marty I think it's pretty
evident that this one had a long day at
the daycare Marty is so clean and smells
so nice and I didn't have to do a thing
how are these things happening magically
this is amazing my life has changed
we're talking about end of the week
Thank You appreciation party for my team
and people on my floor so I've always
wanted to have this really nice party
for my co-workers to thank them for
being so hard-working supportive
basically the best people ever since I
have Kevin why not end this week with a
bang I want Kevin to put together the
best badass party he can and help my
co-workers feel appreciated Kevin's like
plan parties before plans were team
color balloons food Oh in a cake today
is day three going over to Kane's house
it's been a few days Kevin hasn't sold
the iMac yet when you work for a big
celebrity if they say hey I need you to
sell this iMac they don't typically have
this grand number that they want to get
for it in Cain's situation it makes it a
little bit harder to do the job at this
point I just want him to get rid of it I
just want my money and it off my kids
income right now I'm gonna meet the guy
buying his computer it's a success
eight-hundred yeah he sold my iMac $800
in my pocket
finally this thing is out of my mind out
of my sight it's just been taking up so
much physical and mental space and now
it's cold hard cash office loves dogs
but I don't bring Marty's as much as I
want because every time I have a meeting
I have to find somebody - what Marty
since Kevin's here I can take Marty and
the pocket-book agency they came in and
they did their little segment interview
for the video he wants me to remind him
every two hours to drink water so for
some reason I always forget to drink
water and I get really dehydrated I get
headaches and I get tired and I'm not
able to perform my job the best way I
can they don't always have time to be
remembering to literally drink water
they're so busy so sometimes assistants
have to be that person to remind them
those things I'm also constantly
thinking if a task is to beneath him
what if he thinks reminding me about
water is annoying what if he thinks I'm
annoying I'm not used to having a
personal assistant to just do all these
little things for me cane has been
really awesome to work with I just told
him I was like if I could I'd work for
you because you're really cool guys you
want to go pick up some things for the
party to be more prepared for tomorrow
also I have to go do some shopping for
him today I need to remind him every two
hours to drink water cane wants a new
pair of jeans got to be resourceful as a
personal assistant you can't just go to
the store because they didn't have the
ones that he wanted and say oh they
don't have it I decide I would FaceTime
him sometimes you end up learning a
little bit from the principal came took
me up to the roof so one of the nice
things about having a personal assistant
is having someone to take Instagram
photos so we went on the roof and had a
fun time taking photos for each other
and I got to teach him a few tips that I
learned from test videos and I let him
borrow my jacket and it was a fun time
so he taught me how to take an Instagram
photo he does this like one two three
and he takes the picture one two three
he seemed really thankful and happy to
learn some tips that maybe he never
really knew before so Kevin sternum and
and today is Thursday and the shoes
arrived and I'm super excited I saw
these on Instagram
so it's 2:30 and I can't sleep because
of this party this is one thing you want
to get it perfect I'm gonna do my best
to go back to sleep it's day 5 final day
today is the day of the big party and at
the same time I have a big shoot going
on pretty far away from where Kevin is
setting up for the party
I'm not worried I have full faith in
Kevin he's pulled off all the tests so
far and I wish him luck so I'm in the
stairwell I'm looking for Katie it's not
a attorneys phone when I'm directing a
shoot I'm fully focused and totally off
the grid I need to find out if he has
these jugs for the punch and there's a
couple other things need to talk to him
about and I just tripped and I think I
probably sprained my ankle the show must
go on
we got an hour and 15 minutes before the
party I got the balloons i'ma head over
to Gelson's to pick up the cake order
the food things are looking good Kevin
texted me and said he tripped he says
he's gonna continue to finish setting up
for the party and I really hope he's
okay he just ran over for my shoes and
this looks beautiful holy crap I was
blown away there were balloons there was
cake there was food and I was so
impressed by Kevin he was able to push
through even though he had an incident
mad respect for that with my busy
schedule on the schedule that we have at
BuzzFeed like we would never have time
to do something
kevin was able to put it together so
after checking everything out it was
time to invite my co-workers to the
party he pulled it up to the TV I'm in
love with this when you said food I
didn't expect the real food such a
lovely Friday surprise nobody did an
amazing job I'm shocked this nice stuff
never happens I am so grateful one of
the best friends I've seen around here
all the time
I wanna hear the teachers just Kevin I'm
Kevin's proud party was a success so
after the party we try to make sure that
Kevin was okay and so we took him to
Urgent Care to get him checked out to
make sure everything was all good that
was a wild and to a week I was not
expecting I've end up in urgent care and
the doctor took x-rays and made sure
that nothing was broken it's a sprain
and he'll kill back in a few days to a
week thank you so much for your help
this week of course his pleasure came
he's a good employer he's really easy a
lot easier than other people I've worked
for really like Busbee you know the list
of things that you have to do all the
way in the back of your mind that you
never get around to doing this week I
got them all done thanks to my personal
assistant Kevin one day I would love to
have a personal assistant but right now
I don't have enough things for them to
do and also I'm nowhere near being able
to afford one but hopefully one day
[Music]